entre la playa de ipanema y la favela de
cantagalo no hay solamente un enjambre
de callejones un abismo social y racial
separa el mundo del surf del podio
olímpico anderson es conocido como
pikachu comenzó a surfear a los 4 años
cuando iba a la playa con su abuela muy
pronto se dio cuenta de que tenía un don
por la tabla
las personas del mundo del surf en río
de janeiro empezaron a apoyar mi
evolución en 2013 tuve la oportunidad de
viajar a hawai fue uno de los mejores
viajes de mi vida
a pesar de haber ganado varios torneos
locales picacho encuentra dificultades
para conseguir patrocinios el color de
su piel cuenta mucho a la hora de atraer
a las marcas y eso a pesar de que
algunos de los mejores surfistas del
mundo son brasileños como acaba de
quedar patente en tokio con el triunfo
de italo ferreira las empresas no
quieren patrocinar a los jóvenes de la
favela prefieren patrocinar a los chicos
blancos de ojos azules aquí aquí en río
nosotros que nos dedicamos al surf
sufrimos el racismo en nuestras propias
carnes
erika tuvo que lidiar con ese mismo
problema desde la primera competición
supo que quería dedicarse a este deporte
pero no tuvo apoyos y optó por el
periodismo esto de alguna forma me
desmotivó mientras que algunas amigas y
colegas viajaban a hawai a indonesia
participaban en eventos fuera de brasil
yo no tuve este soporte financiero en
aquella época pero para luchar contra la
discriminación en 2019 creó el
movimiento de surfistas negras he creado
una página en instagram una plataforma
gratuita donde comencé a publicar fotos
de mujeres negras para que estas mujeres
sean vistas y para que se conecten entre
ellas desde las redes sociales
erika intentad es construir el
estereotipo de los surfistas rubios y
erradicar lo que define como racismo
estructural